recently i streamed a no death run of
sakura over on twitch
defeating every boss on the way to
immortal severance without a single
resurrection used
now obviously there were a few failures
before this
some were understandable like this death
to the guardian aid i'm dead
i'm actually dead and
some are in places that i didn't even
know it was possible to die
[Music]
but then on run six i did the impossible
i died to the divine dragon they said it
couldn't be done
you only have to run in one direction
they said but you know against all the
odds
i did it and then on the seventh run we
switched the language to the obvious
choice for better
immersion french and turns out
this was le run i do you can watch the
vod over on twitch if you like
and to highlight the feeling of facing
secure's last boss
myself and a really renowned artist
called nogi
came up with this ink panel styled
design that's
available for a limited time on t-shirts
and hoodies link in the description
but i'll talk about it later so why
choose secure for a run like this
well it's because i think sakura has
the best combat of any souls game hands
down
and even though almost every one of my
runs ended in despair
i still looked forward to actually
playing the game and starting again
also i feel like this challenge was a
good way to celebrate the secular one
game of the year and we haven't talked
about that
and i also knew that this run would be
the best way to more deeply
understand what optimal combat looks
like perfect example on screen
actually don't look at that never mind
okay i had to cheese a few bosses to get
this run
but for the most part secure played
perfectly looks good
really good fully understanding a boss
and exploiting all of their weaknesses
it's an art in this game and it's so
satisfying to get a flawless fight
i think that in sakura the combat of
souls sees a way forward
sekido taught us that removing stamina
in a souls-like game
is completely fine as long as you
replace it with other complex systems
and
what better system did they add than the
timed block mechanic
perfect blocks deplete enemy posture
which eventually sets them up for a
death blow
and i'll admit that if eldon ring
doesn't have
some sort of timed block system like
this then
i'll be a little bit disappointed
honestly there's a lot of value
in designing a system that lets us stand
our ground against our enemies
and not just roll around at their feet
in full plate armor
since elton ring is supposed to be more
like dark souls maybe
timing your block might have different
consequences like stopping enemy attack
combos it could
give you a free hit it could reduce
their stamina
it could maintain your stamina there's a
lot they could do
and there's a lot future titles could
learn from sakura
and i think that brings us to the topic
of difficulty
shortly after sakura's release in 2019
there was this
really unproductive discussion about the
difficulty of the game
on twitter and in articles and both
extremes of this debate
really dominated the conversation people
antagonized each other and
an interesting discussion was really
difficult to have
and i never said my thoughts at the time
but here they are
while i personally love how
uncompromisingly difficult
sakura is i can see how it isn't for
everyone
just like sakura has parries and reposts
this
topic has a lot of interesting arguments
and counter arguments so
let's go through some of them first an
important premise to understand
is that everyone experiences difficulty
differently
whether it's your play style your
experience your gear your reflexes
what i find hard might not be hard for
you and vice versa
thus the sense of accomplishment we feel
is relative
and so many people argue that having a
variable difficulty mode
will allow players to make these games
as hard as they like
so that they can better align their
sense of accomplishment
with their own skill level but is this
really a choice that we want
players to be making if demon souls back
in 2009
allowed players to just turn on easy
mode whenever they were having trouble
with a boss
so many players would have taken that
easy way out and they would have denied
themselves a sense of accomplishment
as a result of that and that might have
led to the game
never becoming renowned for its
difficulty and that might have led to
the soul series never becoming
successful in the first place
so you can argue that this goes against
the design goals of the developers
and you can argue that it goes against
the very roots
of the game itself also choosing a
difficulty setting is not always a good
experience for the player
how often have you played a game and
then found an easy mode that's so easy
that you can just beat it by pressing
one button
or maybe you've found a hardcore mode
that's so unfair that you actually have
to
cheese all of your encounters in both of
these cases you aren't properly using
the gameplay mechanics
the way that the developers intended and
having one true difficulty mode makes it
much easier for the developers to
balance the ideal experience and to push
you towards playing a certain way
that they have deemed to be the right
way to play this encourages you to
properly use
all of the gameplay tools that the devs
have put at your disposal
and get the full experience out of the
game but the counter argument here is
that souls games have always had
variable difficulty a lot of people
don't bring this up but
if you're having trouble against a boss
you can just summon help
if you're too weak you can easily look
up overpowered weapons
or spend time grinding your character's
levels to make them stronger
so how is this any different to adding
an easy mode some people might say
well i think what makes this different
from adding an easy mode
is that you're being encouraged to find
your own answers within the game
when you summon someone to help you with
a boss fight you're forging a connection
and learning skills from other players
when you seek out a
overpowered weapon for example you're
learning that the world
has answers to difficult bosses if you'd
only go out and explore more
these things absolutely make the game
easier and they absolutely trivialize a
lot of the fights
but at least you are taking an active
role in changing the difficulty and you
are playing the game in a way that
allows you to change the difficulty
and often it just helps you understand
how to play
however this brings me to sakura since
the game is offline you can't look for
help
or learn from players around you and if
you spend time
chasing powerful upgrades or tools to
get you through a fight
it's kind of just time wasted that
should have been spent
practicing the fundamentals of combat
instead because
you're gonna need those fundamental
skills later in the game
so i do think in regards to difficulty
secure could have done more
on this front it is a shame that a lot
of people probably just wanted
a little bit of extra help when they
were stuck somewhere and
it's a shame that those people miss out
on the other things that make these
games so great like
the stories and the world building and
the immersion
these things would be open to so many
more people if sakura just had a little
bit more give
in it but as it stands the game locks
out a lot of players who
just don't have the time to dedicate to
mastering its mechanics
notice how i said time not skill there
because that brings me to my final point
which is
skill is a factor of time and it's a
factor of how dedicated you are to
overcoming adversity and your own
shortcomings
yes we all experience difficulty
differently and
some have much more to overcome than
others and they should be commended for
doing that
but i believe that almost anyone can
master these games
if they set their mind to it this game
will give back to you if you give it
your time
there's so many examples of that and
surely that's a well-known fact at this
point
so don't be like the elitists who
gatekeep our community and don't be like
the writers who pretend
that practice isn't possible rise above
encourage people and
help others understand why these games
are worth setting aside time
for so does sekiro deserve some
criticism
of course it does but to me this game
deserves game of the year because
it's stuck uncompromisingly to from
software's vision and
that is a trait that i hope they never
lose besides if we ever disagree with
their vision
then mods will save us
anyway i know this video is a bit
different from my other ones
i just sort of wanted to talk about
sakura again since it won game of the
year
and i wanted to make you all aware that
i stream on twitch sometimes now
and i'm planning on doing some more runs
like this in the future
so go and follow over there and unlike
all the other souls games
i'm happy with everything i covered on
sakura and
despite covering secure really
thoroughly though i realized i never
commissioned merge that was really
inspired by it
and who better for this task than nogi
an incredible artist who does these
beautiful hand-drawn
ink prints we made something that was
inspired by the final clash
in secure and it's presented in this
stylish
panel almost comic book style and it's a
design that we're really proud of
and it's available on hoodies on a shirt
and for this week only
you can get the red kanji edition which
is available just this week
and then never again but before i go i'd
also like to give shout outs to
distortion keg witty squealer killer and
charlie bit me these are streamers who
taught me a lot about how best
to complete my run their streams are
mainly challenge runs and speed runs and
watching them is so exciting all the
time because you never know when they're
gonna break the new record
so go and check out all the links in the
description and follow some of these
folks
and maybe consider how you yourself
might want to
chase this sense of accomplishment by
doing a run of your own
but thanks for watching and i'll see you
next time